over there oh just depression
oh my god all right
here's to a history class that won't
give marxism a pass it's true desantis
takes on the world's worst commies and
has lefties crying for their
birthing persons
on monday a day of the week the
president of the republic of florida ron
desantis signed a law requiring students
to learn about communism establishing
november 7th as a state holiday called
victims of communism day or vacti you
can see at a college campus students
flying the hammer and sickle from the
old soviet union flag you will see
students that will have t-shirts with
kevara on the t-shirts you will see
students that will idolize people
like mao zedong
that to me speaks of a tremendous
ignorance
about what those individuals represented
in the evils that communism inflicted on
people throughout the world and so
our goal here uh is to stand for the
truth all right hereafter the only
pinkos florida tolerates are tourists
who forgot to pack sunblock
cause yeah their their skin goes red
right yeah
somebody drug the audience
jokes that bad today huh is that what it
is you're just so intent
now florida is the first state to adopt
this designation but it's the first to
mandate 45 minutes of school instruction
on that day that's not that much
students will learn about lenin stalin
castro mousey tongue jane fonda
once again
bernie sanders is left out
students will also learn how people
under those regimes endured quote
suppression of speech poverty starvation
migration and systemic lethal violence
sounds like portland oregon of course
desantis has already gone after disney
in recent weeks positioning himself as a
leader in the culture war he really made
pluto his [ __ ]
all the more significant considering he
only trails trump and polls on the gop
favorite for president while mike pence
draws less interest than a savings
account
although we shouldn't forget about this
guy who's also climbing up the poles
ah wow
i wish i had some singles
chrissy is this a good idea i know that
i want that guy at my birthday party
that's for sure
uh it's interesting that victims of
communism day is happening in november
at school so what does that mean instead
of hand turkeys they're gonna draw like
han trotsky's
i don't know i don't know
i don't know and trotsky i think that
sounds like a medical condition you got
the trotskys
uh i think any kid that's been forced to
share their snack with the rest of the
class is a victim of communism that is
true
that is true oh i wish i had snacks
tyrus what do you make of this i kind of
you know what here's my theory i have a
theory you're going to like this one
governor desantis's effectiveness as a
governor and a a presidential candidate
he's trump without the trumpism he does
he's all of these things are very
interesting provocative and i would say
it's smart ideas but it's not wrapped in
that cocoon of tweets and brashness so
he actually can he might actually have
learned something absorbed what works
from trump and what doesn't what do you
think of that theory that's pretty good
did you see my care face my care face
was on point
yes
that's really good we've been working on
it together
i have a feeling i'm feeling when i'm
not around you two talk about me a lot
more than i think oh yeah yeah we do it
on our podcast i don't think we've i
don't think we've had one conversation
like what do you do now yeah craig
butterfield yeah you know even have a
code name for me so it doesn't show up
in google searches
you know
he's doing something crazy though
speaking of crazy yeah he's doing
something out of this world like he's
really just
stepping out the box he's fighting with
facts oh wow you know i'll give you a
history lesson on communism
let me guess what they're going to come
out and say i know exactly what to say
it's racist
it's racist but you're teaching us about
the the evil side of of communism and
he's also pointing to people who are for
it to where everyone's going to look at
them so you're only in favor of conor
because most communists are when they're
running the show because they of course
they have to keep you know they have to
keep the money in the power to make sure
it's you know spread evenly amongst the
masses and a few starve along the way
yeah what are you gonna do yeah but so
by isolating the people who are for that
they're going to be like so you also
support this which is the horribleness
of stalin and marx and they see how bad
they start 100 million people died right
on the on the wrong end of communism
that's kind of hard to walk out of yeah
it is were they all racist yeah yeah
you know well the funny thing is when
they look at karl marx and they look at
angel they were ra they were actually
racist
you know they were not they were not
there was no mixing there was no little
tyruses running around
there's no such thing as a little tire
yeah
that made me think of something really
bad you know
cat uh this is like the republican
answer to crt yeah oh you want to do crt
we're going to teach the kids about how
bad communism is but it's the patiras is
right this is actually factual history
and it should be it's not like an
ideology behind this lesson
totally i'm gonna i'm gonna say
communism is bad
um
but the thing is but yeah just you could
honestly you don't have to have a day to
teach it but you just teach world
history and then you can see that
communism is bad but but but but
what do we like isn't it called when i
was a kid social studies what the hell
was that
i i don't know i mean they called it
social studies
that's that was the trend it wasn't
called world history anymore it was
called social studies
and that's when the country fell apart
yeah
because social studies is is racist
because if you're not social if you're
not a social person you're being
excluded from social studies
they need to have lone studies it's
about socialism studies yeah socialism
study but
honestly you have to say that ron
desantis is like if he wasn't a governor
like he'd be so good like at marketing
yeah like this man knows his audience
but this might be like you know what we
all everyone agrees is the worst is
communism like you got to think about
thinking about this is that if like this
sounds like a trump idea yep but it's
not it doesn't have the trump
uh uh veneer on it which means people
can't like
he's like he's like a mountain that
mountain climber has a hard time
climbing because there's no nooks and
crannies like trump has jimmy but he
finds a way no desantis picks really
good fights because the things he's
going after people care about communism
as tyrus said has killed 100 million
people i believe it's the second biggest
killer of all time next to the clintons
[Laughter]
when you really get into the specifics
of what these battles mean to people
because the parental rights and
education bill which is not the don't
say gay bill doesn't mention gay is
popular with parents on both sides of
the aisle it's 62 with parents
republican and democrat combined and
they're trying to you know paint this as
anti-gay anti-transits none of that
parents just know that they're
kindergarten kids they want to fly to
disney and go on a ride called snow
white and the seven genders you know
what i'm saying no no one is waiting in
line two hours for peter pansexual and
desantis is right to know that and
that's why he's winning
yes
and on that note
peter pan sexual
why don't i think of that
i think i think i dated him
well
up next
would you still make your daily commute
if it means getting attacked enroute
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else